[Music]
hey this is david2 and in this video
i'll be walking through new launches for
monitoring and telemetry
stick around to learn about service
directory and network intelligence
first off is something i'm really
excited to share service directory
provides a managed runtime service
catalog
that allows all of a customer's services
to be accessed from a single pane of
class
across google cloud on-prem and hybrid
environments
with service directory you have the
ability to look up services
services can use service directory to
look at each other up by name
instead of needing to know
infrastructure level details like ip
addresses
service directory can be queried via
http grpc
and dns service directory also gives you
the ability
to catalog services developers can
annotate and search for custom
properties on their services
for example if i'm trying to make a
service gdpr compliant
i might also want to use this
information dynamically to have the
service
only be allowed to communicate with
other gdpr compliance services
now instead of having multiple google
cloud apis determining which service is
gdpr compliant
an admin can easily identify all the
services that are gdpr compliant
with the service directory api
to recap service directory provides a
single pane of glass that discovers
registers and catalogs your services for
easy management
the next topic for monitoring and
telemetry is the network intelligence
center
network intelligence center provides a
single console for managing google cloud
network visibility monitoring and
troubleshooting
there are currently four modules to the
network intelligence center
network topology connectivity test
performance dashboard and firewall
insights
today we'll cover network topology and
connectivity test
for starters network topology is a
visualization tool for viewing the
topology of your vpc networks
and the metrics that are associated with
your google cloud resources
network topology shows actual traffic
flows between various networking nodes
including google cloud workloads and
network services like
load balancers and external clients and
associated
performance metrics one thing i'm
particularly excited about
is the ability to view your
infrastructure changes
you can look at topology evolution and
its associated metrics for six weeks of
history
this interactive visualization of the
topology helps reduce the time
spent to monitor and troubleshoot
workflows
it also helps you optimize your
architecture for better performance
and or cost continuing on with the
network intelligence center
will now cover in addition to the
connectivity test
as a refresher connectivity test is a
configuration and route
analyzer that lets you diagnose
connectivity issues
in your vpc network due to
misconfiguration
or due to missing routes when analyzing
network configurations
connectivity test uses an abstract state
machine to model
how a vpc network should process packets
google cloud processes the packet in
several logical steps
with this launch connectivity tests can
take into account the newly launched
hierarchical firewall policy rules
in addition to the previous vpc firewall
rules
for context hierarchical firewall
policies provide you the ability to
create firewall rules
not only at the vpc but at the folder
and organizational level
the connectivity test starts by checking
the hierarchical firewall policy
if connectivity is blocked by a
hierarchical firewall policy rule
the trace includes the name of the
policy if the connectivity is blocked by
a vpc firewall rule
the trace lists the name of the relevant
ingress or egress firewall rule
so this concludes our updates on
monitoring and telemetry
make sure to check out the links below
to get additional details on these new
features
join us again next time to learn what's
new in networking
you